[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
21 février avec 31 jours sans pluie la
France = le triste record du printemps
2020 mais en hiver c'est du jamais vu
aucune période de l'année n'était
épargnée par la sécheresse dans
certaines forêts la côte d'alerte est
dépassée dans une parcelle comme ceci si
on intervient pas c'est la forêt qui va
mourir là on est en face de nous une
forêt qui est en train de mourir quelles
sont les conséquences de cette pénurie
d'eau en France et dans le monde comment
notre agriculture peut-elle s'adapter
peut-on s'inspirer des pays du sud de
l'Europe réponse dans une minute et puis
pendant toute cette semaine un an après
le déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
en analyse les conséquences de ce
conflit gros plan sur l'économie ce soir
les Français face à l'inflation la
souveraineté énergétique une nouvelle
route des céréales les sanction s contre
Poutine et les oligarques en 12 mois le
monde a basculé explication à découvrir
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
donc le constat d'un hiver désespérément
sec avec redam Rabbit
pour s'en rendre compte il faut prendre
un peu de hauteur 30 jours sans une
goutte en plein hiver à 5 euros de
vauzins on n'avait jamais vu ça pourtant
dans cette vallée située entre la
Dordogne et le Lot-et-Garonne des
retenues d'eau existent pour aider les
agriculteurs mais le constat est là 100
mm de précipitation recensée depuis juin
4 fois moins
on sait d'ores et déjà qu'on aura un
problème de remplissage vu l'époque on
est quand même bientôt à mi-février à
mon avis si on gagne encore 20 ou 30 %
de plus ça sera le maximum alors on
s'adapte préoccuper ce producteur de
tomates actif son plan B
oui bien sûr qu'on est inquiet bien sûr
on a investi sur du matériel de
plantation et de récoltes on va faire
l'entreprise à l'extérieur on compense
seulement gagner en faisant de la
prestation de service à l'extérieur sur
des personnes qui auront de l'eau pour
arroser cet épisode de sécheresse
hivernale ne sera pas le dernier et
fasse à la multiplication de ces
phénomènes les scientifiques sont
formelles falloir consommer moins
consommer différemment ça veut dire
qu'on va devoir changer un certain
nombre de pratiques on a parlé cet été
des golf les golfs bah ça peut devenir
compliqué alors à chaque fois c'est des
petits volumes d'eau là aussi mais ces
mesures sont loin de faire uneanimité
pour preuve cette manifestation
d'agriculteurs à Mont-de-Marsan contre
de potentiels mesures de restriction un
mois sans eau scientifique et éleveur
constate le fléau mais sont des unis
pour trouver des solutions
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de notre premier débat Mary
péter Nati bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
hydrogéologue au bureau de recherche
géologique et minières Mathieu bramsoir
bonsoir bienvenue directeur scientifique
de la Fondation farm et chercheur
Frédéric danse bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste écrivain spécialiste
des questions environnementales auteur
de ce livre rencontre avec des écolos
remarquables qui est paru aux éditions
de Lachaux et Nestlé et j'accueille
Frédéric Seysses bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste politique et
éditorialiste pour sens public je
redonne ce chiffre évidemment ce record
si l'on peut dire triste record 31 jours
sans pluie en France en hiver au corps
de 2020 et y aller ça veut dire cumul de
précipitations agrégée sur toute la
métropole inférieure à 1 mm chaque jour
c'est ce que ça veut dire Marie
pétenatti si on compare
au record de 2020 c'est au printemps
donc là on est en hiver ça veut dire
quoi c'est inédit ce qu'on est en train
de vivre en hiver j'ai vu qu'il y avait
en 89 il y avait eu une vingtaine de
jours d'affilés c'est ça
des phénomènes qui sont pas inédits ces
produits dans le dans le passé bien sûr
cette année ça va être très compliqué
parce que ce manque de précipitation va
se cumuler avec une année précédente
2022 où on observait déjà un déficit de
précipitation hivernale et donc une
problématique de recherche des nappes
qui doit se faire à cette époque de
l'année mais est-ce qu'on a déjà eu 31
jours sans pluie en hiver en France
alors je m'avancerai pas sur ces
chiffres là puisque moi je suis la
spécialiste des eaux souterraines et pas
de Météo France mais effectivement là
sur cette sur cette année on a un
déficit de pluviométrique qui s'accumule
mais depuis 2017 on peut voir qu'on a
déjà eu des épisodes précédents
2018-2019 on a sauté l'année 2021 parce
que là il y avait pas mal de
précipitations mais on peut voir que ces
phénomènes se répètent d'année en année
sur ces cinq dernières années Mathieu il
faut peut-être pour vous c'est évident
mais rappelez pourquoi c'est moi divers
sont cruciaux quand on parle de nos
nappes phréatiques alors effectivement
pour l'instant quand on regarde la
nature on n'a pas de plantes ou très peu
de feuilles qui auraient besoin d'eau
mais comme l'a dit Marie on est à une
période de recharge des nappes donc on
fait on est en train de accumuler de
l'eau dans notre corps et les plantes
auront besoin dans les prochains mois
puisqu'on va faire planter les pommes de
terre les endives le maïs le blé dans
les dans les prochains mois et c'est à
partir du printemps puis à partir de
l'été aussi dont on aura besoin de cette
de cette eau et puis les arbres
fruitiers c'est pareil on n'est pas
encore à une phase de de bourgeon qui
qui apparaissent mais très bientôt les
feuilles vont arriver elles auront
besoin de cette eau pour croître si on
n'a pas d'eau ça veut dire que si on a
pas de stock d’eau non plus il est seul
non pas d'eau non plus on aura un vrai
problème de rendement et de production
dans les prochains mois et il y a un
effet de cumulation de de saison en
saison d'une certaine façon si les
nappes phréatiques se recharge pas enfin
ça va être pire en pire est-ce qu'on
peut dire ça je pense que la situation
est très beaucoup mieux décrite par
rapport à Marie mais faut que je pose
des questions
[Rires]
en effet il y a différents types de
nappes en fait il y a des nappes qui
vont être à recharge actives qui vont se
recharger assez rapidement donc qui vont
bénéficier des épisodes plus vieux plus
facilement et se recharger donc en
France actuellement on observe sur
certaines nappes des niveaux plutôt
satisfaisants puis il y a des nappes qui
sont plus inertiels qui vont mettre plus
de temps à se recharger et qui vont être
plus marqués voilà au niveau de ce
déficit et en effet là où on va stocker
l'eau c'est dans les nappes et cette
année la difficulté c'est qu'on est
parti avec des sols très secs et lorsque
on prend souvent la comparaison avec une
éponge que vous laisseriez traîner sur
le bord de votre lavabo qui est très
sèche pour la réhydrater ça prend plus
de temps qu'une éponge qui est déjà
mouillée avec laquelle vous allez suivre
ta plus facilement voilà bien compris
merci merci pour cette comparaison qui
est ultra clair pour moi et donc
j'imagine pour beaucoup de noter les
spectateurs Frédéric dans les moi
j'entends je lis beaucoup le le
l'expression bon bah le retardement pour
évoquer ce qui se passe en ce moment
est-ce qu'il vous semble juste et
peut-être qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour nous dans nos dans nos habitudes de
voilà de consommateurs de citoyens cet
été ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
continuer à alors l'an dernier on s'est
dit il y a eu la sécheresse on a pris
conscience de tout est passé
ensuite il a plu il y a eu la guerre en
Ukraine il y a pas le Mad maintenant on
a complètement oublié et là rebelote
donc il faut se dire que les efforts
qu'on a commencé à consentir en 2022 il
va falloir les consentir tout le temps
c'est comme pour les économies d'énergie
c'est pas un moment donné c'est tout le
temps et là effectivement il y a
certains endroits notamment le bassin
d'urgaronne le Sud-Ouest qui est le plus
affecté à la fois par des mondes d'eau
dans les nappes et par des mondes d'eau
sur les fleuves nota et les rivières
notamment la Garonne ou on va se
retrouver face à un mur l'an dernier on
a pu faire face à ce mur on a pu sauter
au dessus par exemple un agriculteur que
j'avais interviewé pour Marianne qui
habite à qui qui travaille pardon à
péchodié dans le Tarn
50 km à l'est de Toulouse qui a failli
se retrouver sans aucune autre
d'irrigation parce que le barrage des
kamas je crois qu'il devait irriguer lui
fournir de l'eau lui a dit mais non nous
on arrive à la limite de ce qu'il est
légalement possible de fournir donc dans
trois jours on aura plus rien vous
n'aurez plus rien puis finalement en
jouant sur une irrigation la nuit en
allant chercher
de l'eau qu'on a pu trouver sur d'autres
barrages on appuie irriguer mais s'il a
une pleut pas cette année c'est
impossible donc qu'est-ce que va devenir
cet agriculteur concrètement début
juillet même début juillet on ne sait
pas donc si vous voulez la situation
actuelle elle est gérable si on continue
à faire ce qu'on a toujours fait pour
gérer l'eau mais tout le monde autour de
la table discuter ça on sait très bien
le faire en France mais il va falloir
discuter encore plus encore mieux pour
éviter les inévitables conflits d'eau et
leur aggravation possible l'eau c'est
une histoire politique c'est une
histoire humaine faut jamais l'oublier
et donc le conflit ou la guerre de l'eau
c'est une hypothèse française aussi
Matthieu ça pourrait arriver je vous dis
qu'il y a des il y a des instances il y
a le les deux ministres chargés de de la
transition écologique enfin le ministre
et la secrétaire d'État reçoivent ce
jeudi justement pour faire un premier
point le avant c'est dans l'année
d'ailleurs un point sur la situation
hydrographique en France ils vont
recevoir je crois les préfets des 7
grands bassins ensuite donc on anticipe
ça mais la guerre de l'eau est-ce que ça
est-ce que c'est une terminologie que
vous trouvez prématuré exagéré en France
ou une hypothèse qu'il faut vraiment
envisager j'ai beaucoup de difficultés à
mettre guerres et eau dans la même
phrase parce que en fait c'est plus des
conflictualités même si on regarde au
niveau international donc des conflits
qui sont nourris par l'absence d'eau ou
par les problèmes d'accès assez assez
ressources naturelles donc on n'aura pas
de guerre de l'eau parce qu'en France on
a en plus des systèmes des dispositifs
des politiques publiques qui permettent
d'organiser par contre il y aura très
certainement des choix à faire des
priorités stratégiques parce que quand
on parle d'eau on parle aussi d'énergie
donc de production d'énergie on se
rappelle qu'il y a quand même
énergétique mondiale avec une guerre en
Ukraine donc c'est les prix alimentaires
qui sont concernés ce sont les prix
énergétiques qui sont également
concernés et l'eau elle est absolument
essentielle peut-être que vous aurez les
chiffres plus en tête que moi sur le
total d'eau qu'on utilise pour produire
notre alimentation au niveau mondial
c'est 70 80 % des ressources en eau
renouvelables qui sont utilisées pour
l'agriculture pour se nourrir donc si on
en a moins ça va devenir très compliqué
de le faire et quand les gens ont faim
là on est devant des risques forts de
conflictualité vous parliez de choix à
faire on voyait dans le sujet tout à
l'heure la question des golfs alors on
peut se dire c'est anecdotique mais
d'après vous ça fait partie des des
pratiques dans ce contexte qui à
l'avenir dans les années dans les
décennies à venir paraîtront totalement
folle par être totalement inutile non
sauf si recycle le loup et c'est
problème on ne réutilise que 1% des eaux
des eaux usées contrairement à c'est
toujours le même exemple l'Espagne c'est
15% il sera c'est 75 la capitale de la
Namibie où je suis allé c'est 90
donc oui si les Golf réutilisent la
totalité une grosse partie de l'eau
qu'ils utilisent déjà ce sera
anecdotique après faut faire attention
faut jamais oublier que l'eau doit
regagner les milieux naturels donc si on
réutilise tous c'est toujours ça en
moins pour les mines naturelles c'est
une question d'équilibre en permanence
l'eau d'équilibre entre les pouvoirs
d'équilibre entre les usages que l'on
peut faire c'est pour ça que c'est
passionnant ça dit tout sur la situation
de la France est-ce que les prochains
mois là si il se met à pleuvoir beaucoup
ça peut sauver le pré c'est un peu un
sauvé certaines évidemment surtout
celles qui sont plus réactives et dont
c'est plus vérificatif vont rejoindre
justement ce milieu qui stocke l'eau
n'est jamais mieux stockée que dans sous
nos pieds en fait et donc ce sera
décisif dans ces prochaines semaines
parce que la végétation va commencer à
bourgeonner à s'exprimer à vouloir
profiter de ces précipitations et qui
seront moins efficaces pour la recharge
alors il y a beaucoup de thématiques à
aborder on va on va en ouvrir une tout
de suite grâce à tam-train nuit qui doit
être juste derrière le rideau de
sciences publics bonsoir on va parler
des constructions des maisons puisque la
sécheresse a aussi évidemment des
conséquences très importantes sur ces
constructions ça concerne beaucoup de
Français et oui en gros vous avez plus
d'une chance sur deux d'être concernée
le phénomène il est simple en période de
sécheresse les sols argileux se
rétractent et puis lorsque la pluie
revient il y a les sols gonflent et cela
endommage les constructions ça peut
engendrer déficitures de façade des
déformations autour des portes autour
des fenêtres jusqu'à des ruptures de
canalisation c'est dommage il
correspondent à ce que l'on appelle le
risque RGA retrait gonflement des
argiles et il touche exactement
aujourd'hui
48% du territoire français
10,4 millions de maisons individuelles
c'est 54,2 % de l'habitat individuel en
France évidemment quand on habite quand
on est propriétaire de de ces maisons la
question c'est qui va payer les
réparations évidemment alors aujourd'hui
tout assurer paye une surprise ma
catastrophe naturelle mais bien sûr ça
veut pas dire qu'il va être remboursé
c'est même un parcours du combattant
puisque seulement à 50% des communes
qu'ils demandent obtiennent la
reconnaissance de l'état de catastrophe
naturelle parce que les critères météo à
satisfaire sont extrêmement compliqués
et très important or sans cette
reconnaissance et bien c'est impossible
pour les assurer de se faire indemniser
en faisant appel au régime
d'indemnisation des catastrophes
naturelles régime 4 nattes pour les
intimes mais même si l'état de
catastrophe naturelle est reconnu et ben
c'est là encore une loterie à la main
des assureurs d'ailleurs seulement un
sinistre et sur 4 est aujourd'hui
indemnisé et vous savez même si tout le
monde n'est pas indemnisé le régime
aujourd'hui risque de bientôt être
déficitaire et donc plus du tout capable
de couvrir les sinistres parce que les
catastrophes naturelles sont de plus en
plus fréquentes et oui c'est la photo
réchauffement climatique c'est ce qui
explique la sénatrice les républicains
Christine lavard dans un rapport remis
il y a quelques jours elle pointe avec
ce régime 4 nattes un colosse au pied
d'argile un je n'assume pas le jeu de
mots le risque RGA en effet dit-elle à
augmenter de qui sont très importantes
ils représentaient 445 millions d'euros
par an de 1982 à 2017 puis c'est un
milliard d'euros par an entre 2017 et
2020 et entre 2,4 et 2,9 milliards
d'euros pour le seul été 2022 et si on
regarde les prévisions et bien ça ne va
faire qu'empirer le coût cumulé du
sinistre sécheresse va tripler dans les
30 prochaines années par rapport au 30
dernières et en 2040 les prévisions
montrent que le régime n'aura plus assez
de réserves pour couvrir les sinistres
alors face à ce constat le gouvernement
a présenté une ordonnance était au début
de ce mois oui une ordonnance très très
critiquée par le rapport des sénateurs
car cette ordonnance elle prévoit
d'abord de réserver les indemnisations
au sinistre les plus graves bon alors ça
rond avec la logique assurantielle mais
surtout il y a un risque c'est que les
assurés attendent que les petits
dommages dégénèrent en gros avant de
réparer car ils seront alors seulement
remboursés donc ça coûtera encore plus
cher autre point l'obligation d'utiliser
l'indemnisation pour réparer les
dommages sur le bâti alors que parfois
nous dit le rapport il vaudrait mieux
aller reconstruire ailleurs alors pour
la sénatrice il faudrait plutôt prévenir
le risque elle donne deux exemples très
concrets vous pouvez par exemple
installer un système de drainage autour
des fondations pour empêcher l'humidité
d'un filtrer les murs vous pouvez aussi
installer ce que l'on appelle des
barrières anti racinaires qui empêchent
les racines des plantes d'aspirer l'eau
sous les fondations et elle conclut en
disant qu'il faudrait une véritable
stratégie nationale pour développer
financer des techniques de prévention et
pour cela il existe un fond qui
paradoxalement né aujourd'hui pas mis à
contribution c'est le fond Barnier c'est
pourtant le fond de prévention des
risques naturels majeurs elle parle
aussi par exemple du quatrième programme
des investissements d'avenir l'idée pour
elle serait de se centrer sur les 50%
des communes qui ont demandé à être
reconnues en état de catastrophe
naturelle mais qui n'ont pas obtenu
cette reconnaissance et dont les
logements ne peuvent donc pas bénéficier
de la fameuse indemnisation catnates
merci beaucoup thème de toutes ces
explications m'a répété natis ça va
devenir banal ce qu'on est en train de
décrire c'est-à-dire ce phénomène de sol
qui se rétracte qui se regonfle et donc
de maisons qui souffrent le phénomène de
retrait gonflement c'est quelque chose
qui existe depuis très longtemps et
c'est sûr que les pourcentages de
bâtiments de maison qui ont été affectés
par ce phénomène ces dernières années à
cause de la sécheresse c'est forcément
accentué et donc c'est un phénomène qui
est assez naturel lorsque l'eau du sol
voilà s'en va et bien l'argile il se
rétracte et ça affecte les bâtiments et
c'est sûr que ça va être quelque chose
qui va être observé de plus en plus et
sur des bâtiments déjà fragilisés ça
peut avoir des conséquences c'est
presque c'est une question systémique
Frédéric dans les assureurs vont plus
pouvoir suivre quoi alors c'est vrai
pour ça et c'est vrai pour beaucoup
d'autres thèmes qui sont liés au
réchauffement climatique ils vont plus
pouvoir suivre alors sur sur votre
police d'assurance maison à la case de
quatre nattes en 82 c'était 2%
aujourd'hui c'est 12%. la case
catastrophe naturelle ce qui montre une
idée de l'évolution des indemnisations
ce que veulent les assure sans dire
vraiment c'est qu'on en arrête avec le
principe de solidarité entre assuré et
que l'on que l'on stoppe le principe de
l'arrêté de catastrophe naturelle qui de
la vie générale aurait tendance à des
responsabiliser tout le monde je sais
que à un moment ou un autre tu auras un
arrêté de catastrophe naturelle donc je
construis où je veux cela dit les
assureurs ont beau jeu de dire ça parce
que quand vous achetez une maison vous
les appelez sont obligés de vous assurer
jamais vous demanderont si vous êtes en
zone inondable si vous êtes en zone de
rétractation des argiles cela dit étant
donné que le risque RGA c'est le premier
assuré en termes d'indemnisation enfin
le premier qui fait l'objet
d'indemnisation on peut se dire qu'à
l'avenir
si vous voulez acheter une maison sur
une zone à rétractation des argiles
faudra vous assurer tout seul avec une
franchise énorme avec des normes qui
seront imposées par l'assurance mais
exactement comme en zone inondable en
France on peut construire en zone
inondable sans qu'on nous demande quoi
que ce soit au Danemark en Hollande
c'est impossible vous voulez construire
là assurez-vous vous-même donc on oublie
le principe de solidarité entre assuré
au profit d'une meilleure application de
la loi ce qui revient je termine à une
privatisation de l'application de la loi
qu'aucun élu local n'a voulu faire
appliquer et les assureurs vont même
plus loin que ça qu'on vous quand vous
allez sur le Cotentin la plupart des
digues des villes ne sont plus assurés
parce que les assureurs ont estimé que
les villes n'avaient pas fait
suffisamment pour l'entretien de leur
digue eu égard à la hausse du niveau de
la mer on y est déjà en fait alors on va
parler d'agriculture maintenant
évidemment chapitre très important dans
ce débat vous avez vu quelques images
dans notre sujet d'ouverture de cette
manifestation aujourd'hui à
Mont-de-Marsan la FDSEA et les jeunes
agriculteurs des Landes qui
manifestaient contre une éventuelle
réduction des volumes de prélever
prélèvement d'eau autorisés dans le
bassin de l'Adour le département connaît
lui aussi comme tant d'autres un épisode
de sécheresse hivernale important je
vous propose d'entendre la présidente de
la FNSEA Cristian Lambert lors d'une
conférence de presse de on va dire de
présentation avant le le Salon
International de l'Agriculture elle dit
l'important c'est de pouvoir pouvoir
stocker l'eau de pluie quand elle tombe
oui c'est vrai c'est une inquiétude
personne ne veut revivre l'année 2022
les agriculteurs ont déjà anticipé puis
ils ont semé plus de culture d'hiver qui
sont moins exposées au manque d'eau
l'été mais nous avons besoin d'eau pour
toutes les cultures les prairies les
champs les légumes la vigne on peut pas
avoir d'agriculture sans eau d'où
l'importance aussi de faire des ouvrages
pour le stocker quand elle va tomber en
abondance commencer qu'elle peut parfois
tomber de façon diluvienne
Mathieu brin stockelot de pluie avec
alors là elle ne n’emploi pas le terme
parce qu'il est devenu hautement
polémique avec des bassines ou des méga
Massines ça c'est sans doute une partie
de la solution on va je vais vous
entendre là-dessus mais si on essaye
d'être un de d'être un peu plus de
points plus de de recul c'est le modèle
de notre agriculture qu'il faut qu'il
faut réinventer qu'on que certains sont
en train de réinventer sur la question
du stockage de l'eau et de la gestion
pour l'agriculture de l'eau
effectivement Cristian Lambert a raison
on a besoin d'eau de stocker de l'eau
pour pouvoir ensuite l'utiliser on peut
utiliser les nappes on peut utiliser des
bassines on peut réfléchir à ce genre de
dispositif la question est de savoir
c'est pourquoi en fait pour quelle
production vers quelle
objectif stratégique de nourrir est-ce
que c'est pour nourrir des animaux
est-ce que c'est pour faire de l'énergie
est-ce que c'est la question c'est
vraiment savoir le but de ces stockage
d'eau et et effectivement aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on utilise comme pour
stocker parce que tout à l'heure on a
bien dit la terre est aujourd'hui très
très sèche et très aride s'il te met à
pleuvoir beaucoup et pas impossible que
il y a des problèmes aussi de de
ruissellement et donc de l'eau comme sur
cette éponge qui était bien sèche je
vais finalement aller plus vite allévier
que rester sur l'éponge donc on a aussi
des enjeux de gérer ses pluies qui vont
peut-être être plus abondantes que que
prévu et ce fou aussi envisager de
changer les cultures au profit de
plantes moins gourmandes en eau on parle
beaucoup du sorgho cette plante qui est
moins gourmande justement parmi les
leviers qui existent pour adapter notre
système agricole et pour répondre à
votre question aussi Thomas oui on a
besoin de changer notre système de
production notre système de consommation
et notre système de transformation à
faire une révolution copernicienne
effectivement mais on voit que ça passe
pas forcément enfin il y a beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui le font mais voilà il
y a forcément comme toujours quand il y
a des des transformations un peu rapides
parce qu'on est on est face à une
urgence bah ça grince aussi ça proteste
on a certainement pris un retard
important pour adapter notre mode de
production agricole pour trouver comme
vous le disiez des nouvelles variétés
des nouvelles espèces on peut imaginer
il y a énormément de leviers qui sont
mobilisables on a parlé encore cet été
ensemble d'ailleurs du sorgho qui tant à
se développer à la place du maïs alors
il est adapté à certains contextes on
peut aussi essayer de faire de la
recherche pour trouver des types de
variétés de blé de de maïs ou d'autres
pour essayer de de de résister à cette
sécheresse par contre dans le futur 2030
même peut-être même 2040 il y aura des
cultures qu'on pourra plus produire dans
le sud-ouest de la France il va falloir
remonter un petit peu dans dans les
géographies dans les latitudes donc on a
des leviers techniques des leviers
agronomiques
pas forcément pas forcément comme disait
Mathieu c'est à dire que sur un sol qui
est très sec qui n'est pas apte à
recevoir l'infiltration c'est plus si
elles sont ils viennent ça va ruisseler
et tout est et là on va avoir des
problématiques d'inondation qui pose
vraiment des soucis dans le dans le
milieu urbain donc il y a des solutions
pour parce que effectivement on se dit
là il y a un capital d'eau à utiliser
tout à fait il y a une solution c'est de
récupérer ces eaux de pluie là où on
peut la récupérer c'est à dire sur les
toitures donc ça c'est très ponctuel il
y a beaucoup de grosses métropoles qui
favorisent l'infiltration à la parcelle
on a travaillé sur aussi des outils
d'aide à la décision pour comprendre
quelles étaient les sols les plus à même
de recevoir et de réinfiltrer rapidement
ces autres pluies en milieu urbain donc
ça c'est sous forme de cartographies ce
qu'on appelle les analyses multicritères
donc on va identifier les parcelles et
faire en sorte que l'eau qu'on récupère
aille prioritairement versé par celles
c'est ça c'est tout à fait d'accord sur
la région de Bordeaux actuellement sur
la métropole de Bordeaux nous
travaillons sur un projet de
récupération des autres plis à partir
des bassins de ruissellement qui sont
existants et pour une réinfiltration
dans les nappes d'eau souterraine
urbaine qui ne sont pas utilisées à des
vocations d'eau potable pour la stocker
en aquifères et ensuite la réutiliser
pour des usages non potables donc tout
ça ça prend en compte l'aménagement du
territoire et c'est assez complexe
pourquoi parce que ça met des acteurs
autour de la table qui sont pas
forcément uniquement des acteurs de
l'eau des acteurs du paysage de la
planification urbaine et c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'on doit
décidoter en fait les experts les
experts que chacun réfléchisse et
prennent des six enfants et pas non
seulement au niveau des experts mais
aussi au niveau des financements nous
étions il y a peu au CGE à Rennes qui
est le colloque sur la gestion locale de
l'eau et on a beaucoup parlé voilà
aménagement urbain qui se fait souvent à
l'opportunité et pas dans un esprit de
planification pour la transition la
transformation profonde et il y a pas
d'antinomie avec le milieu urbain il n'y
a agricole parce qu'on essaye justement
de de de limiter ses frontières et de
voir comment on peut intégrer toutes ces
activités et tous ces usages pour pour
une meilleure gestion des ressources
mais qu'elles soient aussi de l'eau mais
de l'énergie et alimentaire on est dans
ce qu'on appelle un peu le Nexus voilà
il faut réussir à à intégrer tous ces
compartiments
remarquables que vous avez rencontrés il
y en a qui qui invente une autre
agriculture c'est beaucoup il y en a
beaucoup il y en a beaucoup ils sont
dans la marge du 13 c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'agriculture dit de
conservation des sols c'est-à-dire
compte tenu du fait que la réserve utile
en eau des sols augmente avec la
porosité des sols si on ne touche plus
au sol c'est à dire si on ne les labour
pratiquement plus et si on laisse la vie
s'installer qui va labourrer à toute
petite échelle les vers de terre les
insectes etc les racines des plantes si
on couvre le seul en permanence entre
les cultures de façon à ce que le sol ne
subisse pas les aléas de du temps qui
qui contribuent à une évaporation un
assèchement bah effectivement on
augmente la réserve utile des sols c'est
d'agriculture fonctionne très bien le
corollaire c'est qu'à un moment ou un
autre comme on labour plus on ne
désherbe plus mécaniquement un moment ou
un autre il faut pulvériser un peu de
glyphosate on peut on peut pas raser
gratis le bio c'est très bien sauf qu'au
niveau des sols c'est pas terrible la
conservation des sols qui a plutôt mes
faveurs parce qu'elle maintient la
réserve utile en eau des sols elle est
obligée d'utiliser un peu de glyphosate
et pour l'aider les agences de l'eau
être beaucoup les agriculteurs à passer
en conservation des sols mais c'est pas
encore passé dans le langage commun des
agriculteurs qui sont tenaillés par leur
idée de faire du rendement pour du
rendement ils sont nés dans cette
culture on leur apprend ça dans les
écoles dans les champs d'agriculture et
dans les lisses agricoles mais on est en
train d'y venir parce que je termine
là-dessus la conservation des sols un
très grand mérite c'est qu'elle fait
faire des économies de carburant des
économies de tracteurs des économies
d'engrais des économies de pesticides
sauf herbicides
si c'est un peu surprenant d'entendre le
mot glyphosate dans la démonstration
mais c'est c'est bien il y a pas de
tabou ici il y a quand même une question
vous dites c'est dans l'épaisseur du
trait bon très bien donc pour l'instant
c'est un progrès ça progresse mais c'est
c'est évidemment très très minoritaire
on parle beaucoup de souveraineté
alimentaire
Mathieu est-ce que avec un nouveau
modèle on peut parce que la
soigne-t-elle alimentaire française elle
est déjà un peu fragilisée mais est-ce
qu'on peut l'améliorer la restaurer en
changeant de modèle en allant vers un
modèle plus vertu on peut aller vers ce
modèle vertueux mais ça veut dire de
faire un changement de système qui va
aussi jusqu'à nous consommateurs depuis
le producteur il faut vraiment avoir une
vision de cette transformation de la
semence jusqu'à l'assiette et la semence
c'est essentiel aussi pour activer cette
transformation donc on a besoin de
travailler sur l'ensemble de la filière
l'ensemble des des filières s'agissant
de la souveraineté alimentaire si vous
regardez un peu votre supermarché vous
verrez que beaucoup de vos fruits vos
légumes viennent de loin de des Pays-Bas
d'Espagne etc donc il faut peut-être
aussi changer nos propres modes de
consommation et cette souveraineté déjà
extrêmement fragile on n'a pas parlé
d'élevage on va peut-être le faire après
parce que c'est aussi un sujet très très
important en matière de de gestion de
l'eau et donc cette souveraineté
alimentaire cette capacité à répondre à
notre besoin et à gérer nos dépendances
elle passe par une transformation de
notre système alimentaire et notre
système agricole ça veut dire faire
venir d'autres cultures mais ça veut
dire aussi créer des filières de
transformation on a appris à pas très
longtemps avec la Fondation farm le cas
des légumineuses en faisant discuter
chercheur du Nord agriculteur du Sud du
Sud de la planète un peu du sud de la
France parce que les solutions sont
communes et qu'on peut partager des
innovations et typiquement dans ce cas
là les pois chiches les lentilles qu'on
apprécie tous on devrait en manger
beaucoup plus parce que c'est
extrêmement vertueux aussi sur des
questions de changement purement
technique dans nos modes de production
mais vraiment pour rebondir et je trouve
que ce que vous avez dit est très
important on a habitué et moi je suis
fait des agriculteurs donc à trouver un
problème une solution massifiée et pas
travailler sur la robustesse de notre
système alimentaire et notre système
agricole on avait une agriculture qui
était qui était assez douloureuse sur le
plan physique maintenant elle va faire
mal à la tête parce qu'il va falloir
trouver des solutions adaptées à chaque
contexte à chaque culture à chaque et
donc plein d'outils sont disponibles on
a de la chance en France d'être
accompagné d'autres pays dans le monde
le sont un peu moins on en parlera
peut-être donc ça ça allait à rebours de
ce qu'on fait depuis des décennies en
France et en Europe c'est plutôt dans
une manifestation des solutions si j'ai
bien c'est ça exactement c'est
travailler plutôt sur une échelle
territoriale combinée l'approche filière
et la proche territoriale la proche
territoire pour bien comprendre les
spécificités de chacun mais ça veut dire
qu'il faut mettre tous les acteurs dans
dans en musique en fait autour de ça et
beaucoup moins chimique et mécanique
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une agriculture
agronomique et en plus redonne le
pouvoir de choisir aux agriculteurs
parce que ça l'échelle de la parcelle
que les choses vont se décider vous
pariez des pays du Sud justement
Frédéric on va on va se voir avec vous
que la sécheresse est aussi une question
très politique notamment à
l'international il y a absolument qui
est responsable d'ailleurs de la
sécheresse qui est responsable du
changement climatique et donc qui doit
payer c'est une question qui traverse à
chaque fois les négociations
internationales elle est très concrète
cette question au moment où par exemple
la Somalie est de écrasée par une
sécheresse historique depuis 2020 vous
avez plus d'un million de personnes qui
sont déplacées à cause de cette
sécheresse à l'intérieur même du pays
pour trouver des zones plus vivables 30
millions de personnes touchées en tout
dans cette corne de l'Afrique dans cette
région du continent alors qui doit payer
effectivement c'est la question qu'on se
pose à chaque Coop et notamment la
dernière les pays du Sud souhaitent que
les pays industrialisés qui sont donc
responsables pour eux historiquement des
émissions de CO2 de carbone paye mettre
la main au portefeuille à la fois pour
rembourser les dégâts qui sont causés
par ce changement climatique la
sécheresse les inondations la montée des
eaux rembourser les dégâts mais aussi
payer pour les investissements qui sont
nécessaires pour prévenir les futurs
impacts de ce changement climatique par
exemple construire des digues etc parmi
les voix qui s'élèvent il y a celle du
président kenyan William Routot c'était
il y a deux jours
le changement climatique est une réalité
quotidienne dans de nombreuses régions
du monde et la situation le s’améliore
pas elle empire si rien ne change si
nous n'avons pas une conversation
honnête oui
clairement elles vont pas parler de cela
avec clarté nous n'en n'avons pas parlé
assez fort
de cette question et c'est vrai que pour
l'instant il y a pas vraiment forcément
d'unités globale chiffrée sur les
montants qui doit payer comment comment
répartir d'ailleurs aussi parce que la
notion de pays du Sud est très large et
très vague et englobe des réalités
totalement différentes parmi ces pays du
Sud vous avez certains pays qui sont
très pauvres et qui ont très peu
d'activités émettrices donc ils sont
plus industrialisés qui sont plus
responsables aujourd'hui des émissions
de CO2 et d'ailleurs il y a un grand
pays qui symbolise cette ambiguïté
évidemment c'est la Chine la Chine
la place où on la plaie parmi la place
parmi les payeurs parmi ceux qui doivent
recevoir des fonds puisque c'est à la
fois un pays en développement où le
revenu par habitant est bien moindre
qu'en Occident et en même temps
aujourd'hui c'est l'un des pollueurs
majeurs de la planète en 2023 tous ces
débats donc reste à trancher dans le
langage technique on appelle ça les
pertes et dommages il y a eu une
discussion à la dernière COP sur cette
question un premier accord d'ailleurs
pour créer un fond un fond financier
pour permettre tous les investissements
dont on a parlé commentaire du
Secrétaire général de l'ONU à cette
occasion Antonio guteres ça ne suffira
pas mais c'est un signal politique
indispensable d'après lui le sujet sera
à nouveau en haut de la pile pour la
prochaine COP en fin d'année la cop28 à
Dubaï Matthieu brun le protectionnisme
de l'eau je il est déjà à l'oeuvre dans
certains pays on y échappe pas et le jeu
là je sors de la France ou de l'Europe
le protectionnisme de l'eau vous voulez
dire Thomas la manière dont on peut
finalement mettre des barrières pour
garder ses productions parce que on
utilise de l'eau pour pour produire
juste pour qu'on soit bien d'accord sur
ce qu'on entend
l'année dernière l'année 2022 nous a
montré comment est-ce qu'il y avait des
tensions extrêmement fortes sur notre
capacité à répondre à aux besoins de
notre population il y a des pays comme
l'Inde comme des pays d'Asie du Sud-Est
qui ont mis des barrières pour pas que
leur production sorte parce que il veut
d'abord répondre aux besoins de leur
pays dans un contexte où l'énergie est
cher et dans un contexte où la mer Noire
qui est une offre importante en termes
de céréales blé maïs etc à largement
surchauffé l'année dernière avec des
prix qui sont montés très très haut il y
a des pays vous avez parlé de la Somalie
par exemple qui dépend énormément le
Soudan ou les autres pays de l'Afrique
de la corde de l'Est de l'Est de
l'Afrique dépendent de l'extérieur pour
leurs approvisionnements alimentaires
notamment du Programme alimentaire
mondial qui se va chercher de sa
nourriture notamment en Ukraine pour ces
populations donc on et c'est pas une
folie de chercheurs qui dirait une BD un
peu utopiste que d'imaginer des formes
de conflictualité très fortes avec des
moments où on viendrait à mettre des
barrières autour de nos pays pour se
protéger pour protéger notre
alimentation notre population si on
regarde de au sein de l'Union européenne
vers le nord vers les Pays-Bas on a un
profond une profonde transformation du
modèle agricole à cause de l'azote et
des terres qui sont très très rares les
Pays-Bas c'était le premier exportateur
mondial de produits agroalimentaires et
on dit on va arrêter en fait on va
arrêter ça et nos agriculteurs vont être
ne plus être agriculteurs parce que on
va mettre en danger notre nos ressources
et notre capacité à produire à répondre
à notre besoin ce qui veut dire que dans
un monde qui se ferme les risques de
voir l'absence de coopération l'absence
de solidarité elle est extrêmement
importante
Frédéric zendaye est-ce que on pourrait
s'inspirer vous l'avez évoqué rapidement
là je reviens à la France et un
comparatif international on parle de de
gestion de l'eau de ce qui se fait dans
les pays du Sud de l'Europe alors il y a
l'Espagne et l'Italie on peut aller un
peu plus loin jusqu'à en Israël c'est à
dire que son des pays qui sont
confrontés à la situation que nous on
est en train de vivre depuis quoi des
décennies donc ils ont ils ont réagi ils
ont réagi oui et non alors le meilleur
exemple c'est Israël ils sont les seuls
à avoir fait fleurir le désert comme on
dit en utilisant l'eau au compte-goutte
en réutilisant l'eau maximum on pourrait
s'en inspirer mais comme la Namibie
qu'on connaît mal la Namibie à une
agriculture la nabibi est un pays
relativement riche quand on s'y promet
notamment windoc la capitale c'est assez
surprenant de voir que l'eau est là et
l'eau provient des toilettes qui étaient
recyclées d'ailleurs un industriel
français qui gère tout ça en France on
ne le fait pas oui on peut s'inspirer
des pays pour lesquels les ressources
sont a et qui ont développé ou bien une
gestion à l'échelle ultra locale de
l'eau mais il a là-dessus on n'a pas
trois rougir parce que notre modèle de
gestion l'a exporté souvent vers ses
propres pays et puis deuxièmement un
modèle de recyclage de l'eau voir un
modèle la tendance ultime c'est celle de
l'Australie ou de certains États
américains ou le contenu de sa rareté
très cher l'eau est coté sur un marché
et si vous voulez de l'eau même les
pompiers on l'a oublié mais si les
pompiers ont du mal à arroser l'incendie
en 2018 en Australie c'est parce qu'il
devait la payer très cher et parce que
c'est tôt a fait exploser sur le cours
de la bourse de lourd en Australie donc
on arrivera pas jusque-là mais oui ce
que nous enseigne les pays du Sud alors
pas l'Espagne parce que c'est un mauvais
exemple justement pourquoi l'Espagne
c'est un mauvais exemple mais parce que
l'Espagne c'est c'est la boucle perverse
de la bassine j'ai besoin d'eau je crée
une bassine une fois que la bassine est
vide j'en recrée une autre puis une
autre puis une autre puis une autre
globalement ce modèle des méga bassines
dans des pays en manque chronique d'eau
c'est ce que à ce qu'a montré l'OCDE
dans une enquête passionnante ce modèle
ne fonctionne pas c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
fait que déplacer le problème vers vers
les générations futures donc il y a des
contre-exemple et puis il y a des bons
exemples sur le recyclage des eaux usées
en tout cas vous l'avez dit l'eau c'est
un problème politique et en France on
devrait s'en souvenir ça devrait être un
sujet politique à l'échelle nationale à
l'échelle local l'eau devrait être par
exemple ce sur quoi on adosse les plans
locaux d'urbanisme
il paraît aberrant aujourd'hui qu'un
maire signe un permis de construire pour
une zone d'activité commerciale sans se
demander si auras suffisamment d'eau
sans se demander c'est la centrale
d'épurations et dimensionnée pour
retraités les eaux de cette de ce futur
aménagement ça devrait être un sujet
politique Marie péter l'a dit je parlais
tout à l'heure de la Réunion la les
ministres qui vont recevoir les 7
préfets des grands bassins
français qu'est-ce qui se joue dans une
réunion comme ça en fait on vous disiez
chacun on pense un peu trop dans son
silo les chercheurs etc qu'est-ce qui
peut ressortir de quel est le levier
d'un état face à une situation comme
comme la situation d'urgence dans
laquelle on est alors ce qui joue dans
ces comités
d'anticipation et suivis hydrologique
c'est déjà la d'informer et de remonter
l'information donc sur chaque territoire
ce qui va se passer c'est que chacun va
aussi dire où en est la situation
ensuite il y a le bergère il y a météo
il y a aussi l'état voilà des ressources
en eau qui va être qui va être transmis
et à partir de là on va aussi mettre les
outils à disposition pour comprendre et
comment anticiper voilà les l'évolution
de la ressource en nous sur chaque
territoire parce que ça c'est une
affaire de territoire chaque territoire
ne va pas avoir les mêmes problématiques
et pas les mêmes aussi la même économie
en fait et donc les mêmes besoins en eau
en fonction des différents des
différents usagers on a des modèles qui
existent et c'est là qu'il faut les
développer de plus en plus pour
comprendre comment la ressource va
évoluer en fonction des précipitations
en fonction du manque de précipitation
en fonction aussi de la réactivité des
sols mais aussi des prélèvements et là
il y a un enjeu aussi lors de ces
réunions sur la remontée de la
connaissance sur les prélèvements en eau
qui sont faits dans les différentes
régions
c'est ça
et c'est remontées d'informations
pourquoi on a passé cette tradition
parce qu'on était béni des dieux en
quelque sorte avec le niveau d'eau c'est
à dire ce privilège de l'abondance et
quelque chose qui est
assez fort en France et qu'on a pas su
anticiper c'est ses dimensions là parce
qu'on avait une abondance ou une
soi-disant à abondance d'eau mais ce
privilège il est terminé en fait il faut
vraiment commencer à activement
réfléchir aux moyens dans
d'encourager je mets plein de de
guillemets et de et de de et de
d'hypothèse autour de ça mais rapidement
cette transformation de l'agriculture et
mettre tout le monde y compris les
financements et les financements privés
mais utiliser des eaux usées pour pour
irriguer ou pour arroser ça suppose de
gros investissements je sais pas qu'il
faut faire assez c'est pas si facile à
faire c'est ça il y a un marché pour eux
après il y a pas que la notion
d'abondance on est dans dans un pays
pastorien qui a développé une culture de
l'hygiénisme qui interdit de toute façon
d'aller utiliser on l'a fait une espèce
de blocage psychologique quoi oui mais
on l'a fait un moment les les le
maraîchage en Champagne le maraîchage
autour de l'Île-de-France était alimenté
par les eaux usées parisiennes et on a
vu ce que ça a donné il y a eu quelques
petites catastrophes bactériologiques
donc on a arrêté on a mis tellement de
normes aujourd'hui que c'est devenu
impossible donc il faut un peu revenir
en arrière et revenir c'est là c'est une
autre révolution copernicienne revenir
sur l'hygiénisation à outrance on peut
accepter quelques niveaux de saletés
dans l'eau avec laquelle on ira on ira
arroser nos cultures et ben voilà on a
terminé là-dessus merci à bientôt
dernier mot allez-y je tiens à dire
qu'elle a une réglementation européenne
qui rentre en force en 2023 là sur
l'irrigation et l'usage des eaux usées
traitées et donc avec des seuils et des
normes en fait par rapport à ces
éléments pathogènes et qu'on devra
décliner en loi française voilà pour
d'accélérer ça va encadrer espérons-le
espérons-le merci beaucoup encore une
fois et Frédéric je vais rappeler le
titre de votre livre rencontre avec des
écolos remarquables qui ont publié aux
éditions de La chaux et ni